so why don't you eat vegetables because
they're they cause inflammation
don't stop
especially especially the green leafy
ones don't stop especially because so
they have they have anti-nutrients okay
multiple anti-nutrients one of the worst
is oxalates and you'll find that in
spinach you'll find that in almonds
you'll find that in many plant foods and
actually that's so bad too yeah
um so if you if you're thinking of not
having arthritis you want to avoid those
what's wrong with the air fryer no off
fries
some things that produce like uric acid
that's right like stiffness
[Laughter]
so vegetables are button this is good so
can I excuse me I'm young lady do you
believe what would you offer
take 10 pills a day that somebody's
giving you to say these are what you
need or eat a veg
I would eat meat and not take no I mean
if you had to eat veg or take these all
these tablets
what do you what do you eat in a day can
I have like a you like steak and expert
and I'll let you have steak do you
really want to hear it you're probably
gonna be shocked okay go ahead so for
breakfast I regularly have 10 eggs 10
eggs and I started boiling them because
there's no mess they come out perfect
and they're soft in the middle
um for lunch I might have 10 eggs again
or I might have some sort of
burger patty I eat a lot steak
um chicken chicken fries sometimes I
don't ever go for chicken breasts
because that's just dry and disgusting
it right no wrap it in bacon wrap it is
streaky bacon yeah it's still dry once
you go once you've got no once you go
all red meat it's different
because I'm just I'm struggling to wrap
my head around no vegetables because
then as an athlete I kind of have to oh
yeah so you'd do better you think so
yeah I know because I'm kind of like so
does that work so I work for a doctor
who is 56. he is he lives in America and
he is world champion at Rowan at 56. he
has improved his strength he's been
Carnival seven years
um and he has improved everything he got
rid of all of his illnesses wasn't it I
mean for that diet that came up years
ago that used to be called zero carb
then it went to carnivore diet
um but you know it's just I mean before
that I'm sure there was somebody that
disabled me there was a diet going
around years ago oh yeah it's called um
the lion diet oh and the lion diet yeah
but no that's not before that that's the
news no that's before the newer diet way
before that yeah
do you mean Primal no
I can't remember what it was but this
guy was just eating me on there he was
just slapping up the meat in front of
them I like him
guy liver oh liver King yeah he lied
though didn't he he lied a lot wait so
10 eggs then 10 eggs again maybe not a
steak do you know what I can understand
the state where the hell do you put 10
eggs I can't eat two eggs really no yeah
well you eat you eat to what your what
you need nutrition you're talking boiled
yeah I can manage one
do your kids eat only meat too I would
love them too but no they have varied
diet
they do but they don't actually want veg
or such they like fruit
and I don't matter so there's some
stories so when they were younger I used
to make them eat their veg and um they
come up with some really good ideas of
how to hide the Vegeta sometimes they
quickly open a window and hide it in the
barbecue or or they'd quickly put it
under the table and then I would
um assume it was the wrong child and
make the other child pick it up and eat
it
and the other one just let them do it
yeah so now they're thankful they're
like yeah so it's eggs
a lot of eggs chicken a lot of red meat
lamb is my favorite wow the Lamb's
expensive right now you should you would
love it in Morocco venison the other day
all right so so there's a local there's
a local Hunter who actually
um so you know there's a vegan argument
that actually is wrong to kill animals
well I have someone who is a hunter
that's local actually he goes to the
crop fields and he has to protect the
vegetables and he shoots all the deer
and whatever else there and then I
managed to get a hold deer for 25 pounds
can I have one
[Laughter]
um
how long have you been doing the diet so
in eight points four years wow wow do
you have like a before and after yes is
it on you yes wait can you can we pull
it up but I know this is off topic I'm
just like really I'm curious as well
there we go there's a there's a video
you'd have to play the video okay can
you play it I just yeah I just want to
be honest for myself okay honestly okay
and I'm also really excited that
vegetables are bad for you they are so
do you like this one don't get your
crutches out okay
she's about getting the crutches out
do you know what it is right she came
back from America with a load of pills
oh okay right and I said do not take I
don't believe in taking all these
supplements I'd rather you have meat and
two veg oh so it's supplements yes yeah
so yeah yeah
you don't need supplements I don't take
no supplements so I I actually consider
salt a supplement which is could be
strange I eat salt a lot yeah rice no do
it what do you say do you use that no
bread no carbs at all is it on your
Instagram yeah
it is because it's a pinned post I like
um Himalayan salt where it says there's
a before and after well I always just
like this it says it says watch me
Transformers you guys both look young
I'm into the deer I wouldn't mind having
one of them dares I'm into the disc I've
been doing it about a year I lost weight
I have fell off track a couple of times
and I do cheat but I've I feel better
than I've ever felt so where's the
before Oh you skipped past the before
the before is first yeah blessing what
are you doing
um it's just perfect come on wow oh wow
so that was during
oh my God you look completely different
you do yeah a lot of Happy Food a lot of
butter a lot of butter
and
actually not much exercising to be
honest but how often do you exercise Oh
there's uh so I used to before
lockdowns I dance sometimes in my heart
this is embarrassing oh God
I mean I'm just like she looks good
she's like skinny as hell
um
sorry when you said supplements are bad
are you referring to all vitamins or
because personally I take creatine and
collagen so were they look you know bad
for me then it depends what collagen and
creatine you're taking but
um from my protein I don't get a
specific one collagen from my protein is
very good oh good yeah it's really clean
it's got nothing in it if you go to
other places they have soy in it and
things you don't want to have soy yeah
you want to avoid soy it affects your
estrogen levels especially in men
um but yeah I I got collagen just
because when I lost the weight my hair
started falling out because you know
your nutrients go from there to there
and so just wondering how it is you must
have been cutting your calories quite
drastic see for me my weight loss
happened whilst I was eating four to
five thousand calories a day my weight
loss didn't happen by starving myself I
literally eat until I'm bursting
then I eat so I'm bursting then I
started I was writing that I tell Pearl
she doesn't eat enough she needs to eat
three times a day and snack any of my
clients for under e don't lose weight
yeah see I was right right on that yeah
she was leading me astray with the
vegetable yes she was cheers
for nothing what were the supplements oh
I don't even they're too oh there's some
great big pissary looking things they're
massive she got from America you know
you know Americans and stuff are full of
rubbish my mom my mom gave it to me I
was like okay I'll try it
but yeah about what you were um saying
about calorie counting just because you
know I am
because you said you were using about
four five thousand regularly over five
thousand well well for me
um I had to figure out what my
maintenance calories were
um and I just I started off at 330
pounds which is absolutely insane
thinking about it now
um and gradually you know my calories
went down from you know 3 000
maintenance to 2500 so you know lower
and lower until about 1500 which is too
low for me it's not because
um
you will do damage stop your health long
term
well there's different ways of doing it
I mean not ever sorry I've kind of
overtaken everything but the meat thing
isn't for everyone I think it would
benefit everyone but mentally people
can't do it
um
every client that I coach
reverses all their health issues some of
them my clients go from being completely
bed-bound to then be able to be up and
exercising and doing things this isn't
cutting calories so a lot of my clients
go from 900 calories a day and I
increase it some some of those increase
it to 5000 and they start losing weight
when they're at 900 calories they
stopped you reduce your metabolism when
you do that yeah and then every time
you've got to keep cutting it back and
cutting it back to try and make a little
bit of loss well what you're losing
essentially then when you're under
eating is 50 muscle and 50
um fat so well for me um because I know
it varies with everyone you know weight
loss and health isn't linear which would
be easier if it was
um but as I've gradually you know lost
the weight because I do this thing
called a body composition obviously
you're into fitness you'll know what it
is that's the scan
um it's essentially where it it measures
your muscle compared to your fat and
your hydration
um with being on 1500 calories don't get
me wrong you know there are days where I
go over but I pretty comfortably stay on
that and
from my body composition my muscle has
gone upwards on the you know graph and
my fat has gone lower for me you know
partially right perhaps it will change
for me but someone who's had issues with
food growing up and I I just want to
make sure I can maintain a healthier
weight obviously I'm not healthy now
I've lost
God was it now 122 which is amazing yeah
which is amazing but the the dexa scans
and all those scans are not accurate and
actually if you drink water before you
do one of those scans it will show you a
higher body
um muscle mass I read that I thought
it's been bad with hydration so nine
times out of ten I've not drank water
before um so what I'm saying is they're
not accurate so it's not a it's not a
good way to determine actually calipers
are much more accurate so what I just
personally think right that
just eat
a balanced diet
Foods no processed foods and the best
quality foods that you can buy yeah I
agree I think that's what it is so but
you're gonna buy steak I had a steak and
it was massive and it was really good
and it was 30 quid and I cooked it
outside in the garden
because it was that was the instructions
you get to get a skilly and like eat you
really up with loads of butter and it
was all smoking and I like my medium and
that's all I could eat was just the one
steak because there was no room for
anything else but I just think a
balanced diet and eat often that I don't
I don't watch calories I don't watch
calories I eat what I want and um I
think Grandma's gonna eat more other
than you ate one of the most people but
not more than ever I like to eat a lot
it's like not rubbish food no processed
stuff I agree with everything but eating
regularly eating regularly is just gonna
spike your insulin
um fat storage hormone that's not a good
thing so if you can eat enough in each
meal to sustain you I so I I eat three
meals a day that's that's fine and I
don't need to eat any more than three
meals a day I'm full updates regular
free meals a day yeah yeah that's what
I'm saying um so and some people think
you need to eat six times a day but
that's just spiking your insulin I'm
trying to get helped me three times a
day yeah you do yeah and I have a hard
time doing three yeah
I was gonna ask what would So based on
like my circumstances as I've said
because I you know gradually gone down
from you know three thousand to about
fifteen hundred and when I've because
I've actually gone to 1700 and I like
consistently gained weight from that
um so you know as someone who is a
trainer what would your like opinion be
if I'm losing consistently not losing
loads at 1500 I'm losing a pound a week
but I'm losing it consistently okay so
first I would say throw away the scales
second I would say you need to do a
reverse diet where you increase the
calories you need to trust the process
you need to allow your body to fire up
again and get everything working you
know when you're starving yourself your
natural ability to know when you're
hungry and know when you're full is
Switched Off
so you need to get all those things in
your body working again
um come outside everybody's saying well
if you were these women would they can't
even know Beast man no yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't because he is not taking care
of himself he's unhealthy I mean
naturally if you think back years any
animal goes for another animal mate
because they're healthy why would we go
for someone that's not and what if they
didn't know how to be healthy like say
somebody didn't know how to cook I had
to do that I'm a strategist but if I
thought he was cute I'd just feed him
less
you can't build a man no it's the same
it's the same
time
and I just wondered like you know no in
general what do you mean obese do you
mean someone who looks particularly
overweight because
when you talk about the BMI on that
skill they're obese on the BMI
and so you can get that from a
bodybuilder even that's got no food they
can be so the BMI is not a good but I
mean I wouldn't go on bodybuilder
because I think they're too big so
that's what I mean so would you go with
somebody that's flabby then Phantom
flabby not built yeah
she said yeah
you have been there that's why
yeah maybe yeah
I know they're taking care of them know
they're on a better journey and it's not
them being sedentary and just doing [__]
who I've been now I just I just wondered
have you ever been has anybody ever been
out with somebody other than us
[Laughter]
[Music]
I just wanted because sometimes I find
that the women will not mind the men
taking them when they're fat and
overweight but they won't take them in
when they're fat and overweight
the women that go with the men and say
yeah I'm fat I'm going to lose weight or
they put on weight and they say I want
to lose weight I might get fat
um
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible